We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a funny, kind of interesting but also
prescient voicemail.
This is from a foreigner who just doesn't
understand how Trump is able to get away with
lies all the time.
Take a listen.
Hey, David.
This is Andre calling from Wolfsburg, Germany.
Yes, I've got a question.
Could you please explain to me why the media,
Barrack Obama, Joe Biden and the rest of the
Democratic Party do not rip Trump apart for
the B.S. and the lies he keeps telling on
a daily basis?
I mean, any of these lies and false allegations
which Trump has been spreading over the last
couple of weeks would have been political
suicide in Germany.
Yes.
I mean, to me, the media and the Democrats,
they seem like victims that are too afraid
to stand up against the bully.
What do you think about that?
Yes.
So listen, I understand the total bewilderment
around the world at what is going on.
Trump is a laughing stock, and yet he doesn't
seem to sort of suffer the consequences.
This is only partially because of Democrats
and it's only partially because of the media.
I've talked before about how when Trump lies
at a press briefing and he gets called out
on the lie, he will tell three more lies and
then move on to the next reporter.
And it's very hard to control that.
Or he will simply end the press briefing early.
And these things in the United States are
not proving to be political suicide.
Why?
Because you have such a partizan environment
that half the country doesn't care or half
the country sees Trump leaving early from
a press briefing as a sign of power, or they
simply believe everything he says.
We have such a broken, critical, critical
thinking has broken in the United States.
And so I get it.
People you know, my family from Argentina,
my family that lives in France, my family
that lives in Israel, they see what's going
on in this.
What?
How are people not just calling Trump out?
And how is it not hurting him politically?
You have to understand the degree of ignorance
and partizanship that exists in the United
States to really understand the answer to
that.
And it is very, very ugly.
On the bonus show today, we will talk about
Jorge Floyd.
We will talk about Kelly Loffler.
We will talk about Ronda Santurce and much,
much more.
Get instant access to the bonus show at join
Pacman dot com.
Very much.
Look forward to speaking to you that.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.